[Musique]
c'est chacun pour soi dieu pour tous tes
coups politiques n'a jamais été obligé
de dire la vérité d idée courageuse des
mots qui compte
onze soir vient de l'ignorance
aujourd'hui on a une gauche extrêmement
sujet d'internet
[Musique]
tous les témoins de notre époque sont
dans la grande interview
[Musique]
les valeurs de la république doivent
être défendus quand certains jouent la
carte du séparatisme
[Musique]
situation plus que jamais chaotique dans
les rues d'almaty au kazakhstan
véhicules calcinés façades détruites et
stigmates de sept jours de violentes
manifestations nées du hall de la hausse
gaz sont partout dans la capitale
économique d'asie centrale pays où le
président ordonne de tirer à balles
réelles pour disperser des protestants
[Musique]
emmanuel macron persiste et signe le
président dit assumer totalement ses
propos controversés d'il ya deux jours
dans lesquelles il souhaite je cite
emmerder mais non mais une nouvelle
sortie du chef de l'état alors que les
syndicats d'enseignants appellent à la
grève jeudi prochain pour dénoncer une
pagaille indescriptible dans les écoles
en raison du pays
la crise sanitaire qui impacte le monde
des finances quelles économies en 2022
après une année
tu sors rebonds
pour son arrivée du barrio mikron sème
le doute comment notre économie
peut-elle s'adapter à un monde qui
change si rapidement éléments de réponse
dans un instant avec l j'accepte
[Musique]
excellente soirée à toutes et à tous
très heureux de vous retrouver sur arte
france pour une nouvelle demi heure
d'information confusion et tensions au
kazakhstan ce pays d'asie centrale est
secouée depuis dimanche par des
protestations violentes années de la
hausse du prix du gaz un bilan des
dizaines de morts du côté des
manifestants et des policiers et ces
derniers qui sont désormais autorisés à
tirer à balles réelles sans
avertissement par le président kazakh
kassim hadjamar tokayev qui qualifie et
le site d' absurdes les appelle
notamment à l'étranger de négocier avec
les contestataires en vue d'une
résolution pacifique de la crise
françois disque et beach avec sébastien
chabal
dernier soubresaut de violence cette
nuit au coeur de la capitale du
kazakhstan almaty la pression des
retombées qu'au petit matin un retour au
calme salué par le président
kazakhstanais l'asim jomart tokayev qui
a fait une promesse au passage le rejet
de toute négociation et l'élimination de
ce qu'il désigne comme des bandits armés
accusés d'être au coeur des émeutes
meurtrières qui secoue le pays
les terroristes continuent d'endommager
les biens publics comme privés
d'utiliser des armes contre les citoyens
genre donné aux forces de l'ordre et à
l'armée d'ouvrir le feu pour tuer sans
sommation
des appels sont lancés de l'étranger aux
parties pour qu'elles mènent des
négociations afin de résoudre les
problèmes de manière pacifique
quelle idiotie quelle négociation
peut-on mener avec des criminels des
meurtriers
nous avons dû lutter contre des bandits
armés et entraînés ici aussi bien qu'à
l'étranger
un chaos que le chef de l'état considère
à présent maîtrisé les autorités
kazakhstanaise affirment avoir repris le
contrôle de la mairie et de la résidence
présidentielle
incendiée par des émeutiers
l'ordre constitutionnel a été largement
rétabli dans toutes les régions les
forces de l'ordre et les forces armées
et apparentés assure l'ordre public la
protection des infrastructures
stratégiques et le nettoyage des rues
les organes locaux ont le contrôle de la
situation mais les terroristes utilisent
toujours des armes et endommagent les
biens des citoyens
les opérations de retour à l'ordre
public se poursuivront jusqu'à la
destruction totale des combattants
ces derniers jours la ville d'almaty a
été le théâtre de protestations
violentes
le leader kazakhstanais a appelé à
l'aide les forces de maintien de paix de
l'organisation du traité de sécurité
collective composée d'unités des armées
biélorusse arménienne tadjik kirghizes
et russes le président kazakhstanais a
d'ailleurs tenu à remercier son
homologue russe les unités du contingent
des forces de maintien de paix de l'eau
tsc ont pour objectif de stabiliser la
situation dans le pays la mission
principale des forces collectives de
maintien de la paix de l'hôtesse et sera
d'assurer la protection des sites
étatique et militaire important est
d'aider les forces de l'ordre de la
république du kazakhstan à stabiliser la
situation et à assurer le retour de
cette dernière dans le cadre légal
de la part de la fédération de russie ce
sont des formations et des unités
militaires des troupes aéroportées qui
intégreront les forces collectives de
maintien de la paix de l'hôte et sc
selon les autorités kazakhstanaise les
derniers manifestants situé sur la
principale place publique d'almaty ont
été délogés ce jeudi par les forces de
sécurité une situation qui terrifie les
habitants d'almaty local down ce quasar
owen voyous quand le président a dit
qu'il était en guerre contre les voyous
il nous a traités de voyous en guerre
contre les terroristes
nous ne sommes ni voyous ni terroristes
nous manifestons quand il a dit cela
j'ai été profondément déçu
je n'ai jamais pensé je n'aurais jamais
cru que notre peuple était si terrifiant
c'était très effrayant d'être dans la
rue et nous ne pouvions pas dormir la
nuit parce que nous avions peur nos amis
nous ont envoyé des messages en nous
disant de ne pas sortir il y avait des
gens qui entré chez eux
l'état d'urgence et un couvre-feu à
l'échelle nationale ont été instaurées
tandis qu'internet et les communications
mobiles étaient toujours bloqués ce
vendredi matin
les terroristes continuent à endommager
les biens et à utiliser des armes contre
les citoyens se sont donc les mots
employés tout à l'heure par le président
kazakh qui allait coûter justement à ce
sujet le géopolitologue emmanuel dupuis
il est le président de l'institut
prospective et sécurité en europe
dès qu'un pays se sent menacé et c'est
le cas tout cas c'est comme ça que le
président kassim jomart tokayev a évoqué
les pays partenaires les autres
partenaires la biélorussie l'arménie le
tadjikistan et le kirghizistan et la
russie sont légitimes pour aider un des
pays agressés no - vous avez mentionné
dans votre reportage que le président du
kazakhstan évoqué de l'organisation
terroriste ont quand même ce n'est le
fait affirmé plus tôt que la
responsabilité venait de l'organisation
et de groupes formés à l'étranger ce qui
pourrait justifier au titre 1
administrativement parlant pardon du
l'utilisation de 2,7 de ses troupes de
maintien de la paix ils sont plus de
3000 3 2600 russe de sang du tadjikistan
502000 russie 70 d'arménie en tout cas
c'est dans ce cadre que cet appel à
l'aide a été formulée par le président
du kazakhstan
paris londres berlin et washington et
l'onu se relaie pour appeler à la
désescalade au kazakhstan idem pour
bruxelles et ce alors que la président
de la commission européenne était à
l'elysée tout la ruhr soula von der
leyen accueillis par emmanuel macron
dans le cadre de la présidence française
du conseil de l'union européenne
l'occasion d'apporter le dossier
ukrainien alors que les négociations
entre moscou et washington à ce sujet
s'ouvre lundi à genève dans secrétaire
d'état américain anthony blinken estime
ce soir qu'une solution diplomatique
avec la russie à je cite encore possible
voyais à ce propos l'analyse de claude
blanchemaison expert en relations
internationales
la question était est ce que l'europe
est absent de cette discussion et
monsieur macro comme à la baule aliens
ont dit mais il peut pas y avoir de
discussion conclusive sur la sécurité en
europe sans les européens donc il faudra
bien que d'une manière ou d'une autre
les européens
reprennent la main dans cette effusion
c'est une bonne chose qu'il y ait des
discussions bilatérales entre les
américains et les russes mais il faudra
bien à un moment donné que les amériques
que les européens reprennent leur place
puisqu'ils sont concernés au premier
chef monsieur mâcon comme madame renée
arrivée n ont rappelé que le format
européen pour discuter du sujet était le
format normandie avec l'allemagne la
france le représentant de l'union
européenne pour les questions de
politique étrangère l'ol c'est eux la
russie et l'ukraine
et lors de sa conférence de presse
commune avec our souls à van der leyen
emmanuel macron a été interrogé au sujet
de ses propos polémiques dans le
parisien cette semaine concernant les
non vaccinés contre le coc u19 une
catégorie de personnes que le président
a souhaité je cite vouloir emmerder
jusqu'au bout il persiste et signe
qu'on peut s'émouvoir sur des formes
d'expression qui paraissent familière
que j'assume totalement moi je m'émeus
de la situation dans laquelle nous
sommes la vraie fracture du pays est là
quand certains font de leur liberté qui
devient une responsabilité un slogan non
seulement ils mettent en danger de la
vie d autres mais ils restreignent la
liberté des autres ce que je dis c'est
qu'être citoyen c'est aussi accepter les
devoirs qui vont avec cette citoyenneté
une nouvelle sortie du chef de l'état
alors que les principaux syndicats
d'enseignants déposent aujourd'hui
un préavis de grève pour jeudi prochain
ces derniers dénoncent je cite une
pagaille indescriptible
en raison de la crise sanitaire nouvel
indicateur épidémique ce soir près de
330 mille nouveaux 4 coronavirus
recensés ces dernières 24 heures les
écoles sont particulièrement impactés
avec plus de 9200 classes fermées et de
nombreux professeurs absents près de
cinquante mille élèves testés positifs
depuis le début de la semaine un nouveau
protocole sanitaire allégée est en place
depuis ce matin benjamin amar
enseignants et porte parole de la cgt
dans le val de marne déplore une
situation ingérable
à écouter les bras les bras nous en
tombent quand même là parce que s'il est
la situation à l'école et elle relève du
chaos
cia il ya énormément d'établissements
scolaires en france où il y a
effectivement entre un tiers et la
moitié des élèves qui sont qui sont
absents moi je vous l'avais rappelé je
suis responsable syndicats dans le val
de marne dans mon établissement je suis
enseignant dans un lycée il ya 92 élèves
contaminés au co vide pour un lycée qui
a autour d'eux je dirais autour de 1100
élèves
c'est considérable et on était dans une
semaine d'examens d'analysé c'est à dire
que les flux n'étaient pas les plus
normaux ils n'étaient plus moins
importants que d'habitude dont j'ai eu
cours avec une classe là moi ce cet
après midi j'avais 60 % des verts
absents
quelle continuité pédagogique dans ce
cadre là quel sens ça de parler de
continuité pédagogique
dans ce cadre là elle colère des
enseignants donc colère également des
soignants de strasbourg à marseille en
passant par bordeaux plusieurs centaines
de blouses blanches ont observé cet
après midi une minute de silence motif
alerte et je cite sur la mort annoncée
de l'hôpital public une nouvelle action
de ce type est prévue vendredi prochain
à 14h écoutez ce médecin un urgentiste
bordelais qui décrit une situation
catastrophique dans son établissement
partout en france c'est que si on a
passé le cap du moment où on soigne les
gens moins bien actuellement on les
soigne
on a des patients qui n'ont plus accès
aux soins à des patients qui passent
plusieurs jours des brancards avant
d'avoir accès à une salle
d'hospitalisation
on a des patients qui donc littéralement
plus accès aux soins qui ont des
séquelles on a des patients qu'on a
soigné dans les douches et on a des
soignants qui ont été agressés parce que
le bouton de sécurité de marché plus on
a des jeux des soignants qui se
suicident donc on a passé un cap à la
crise sanitaire qui impacte également
l'économie à quoi s'attendre pour cette
nouvelle année après un fort rebond du
pib de près de 7% en 2021 le variant
omicron sème le doute avant l'arrivée de
cette nouvelle souche le consensus
tablait sur un atterrissage en douceur
avec un taux de croissance soutenu à
plus de 3% mais qu'en est il aujourd'hui
la france va-t-elle devoir comme
l'allemagne révisé ses prévisions à la
baisse et plus généralement comment
notre économie peut-elle s'adapter à un
monde qui change si rapidement on en
parle tout de suite avec notre
économiste à jacques sapir
jacques on nous annonçait il ya quelques
semaines encore une reprise vigoureuse
qui se poursuivrait en 2022 et qu'en est
il aujourd'hui
bonjour grégory en fait les perspectives
pour 2011 à 2 sont désormais marquée par
une assez grande incertitude il ya
évidemment l'arrivée du variant micro ça
tout le monde à le comprendre qui est
plus contagieux mais qui peut-être aussi
moins dangereux que le variant delta et
ça modifie la donne après il ya de
fortes probabilités pour que l'activité
économique soit globalement backed et
par la montée à l'explosif de l'économie
et de pardon de l'épidémie et du nombre
de contaminations au delà aidé il faut
savoir quand même que les problèmes
économiques se sont accumulées ces
dernières semaines voir dans le dernier
trimestre des organisations des chaînes
logistiques la persistance de
l'inflation dans de très nombreux
secteurs sont des facteurs qui nous
faudra prendre en compte enfin il y a
quand même ce qui se profile t d à la
fin des aides et donc l'économie va
revenir dans un monde plus réel et cela
ne sera pas sans conséquences
jacques la première question qui se pose
c'est celle de la croissance
2022 est ce qu'elle sera aussi bonne
qu'espéré cette année-là alors ce qu'on
constate déjà c'est que pratiquement
dans l'ensemble de nos partenaires et
bien les prévisions sont en train d'être
révisée très fortement à la baisse ça a
été le cas en allemagne c'était le cas
au royaume uni en espagne et même en
italie qu'en france
normalement après une reprise de 6 7% on
escompte et pour 2022 que des
perspectives qui était plus favorable
elles ont été un baisser mes 2 0 1 point
par la banque de france et cette
révision par est finalement très bénigne
et elle n'est pas cohérente en réalité
avec ce que l'on sait du niveau
d'activité de nos principaux partenaires
donc je crains qu'il ne faille
s'attendre à de nouvelles révisions
durant l'année 2022 tous les cas durant
le premier trimestre 1 comment est-ce
qu'elle s'explique sur un million alors
ces révisions s'expliquent par un
élément conjoncturel et par un élément
structurel l'événement proviande sûrs et
j'en ai déjà parlé c'est évidemment
l'épidémie du varions micron et son
impact sur l'économie vous savez qu'on
s'attend à ce que le pic soit vers l'ami
voir la fin janvier donc cela va
entraîner une très forte des
organisations de l'activité économique
du fait du nombre important de personnes
contaminées plus décathlon tac les
arrêts maladie vont très probablement
exploser d'ici la fin du mois après il
faut quand même savoir qu'il y ait un
phénomène qui est plus structurel c'est
évidemment les pénuries de matières
premières les pénuries de produits
manufacturés ces gars-là la pénurie des
microprocesseurs et de ces pénuries
limite actuellement le redémarrage de la
production dans de très nombreux
secteurs elles vont continuer à se faire
sentir pendant au moins le premier
semestre de 2022 voire plus alors même
si des pays commence à en voir le doubs
c'est le cas du japon en particulier qui
semble avoir surmonté le phénomène des
pénuries qui désorganisent la production
eh bien elles vont continuer d'être un
frein extrêmement importante à la
reprise de l'activité en france au moins
je vous le dis sur la première moitié de
cette année mais jacques que ses
révisions vont mettre en cause la baisse
du chômage qu'on constate ces derniers
mois oui absolument grégory absolument
on ne pourra avoir les prévisions qui
sont fait actuellement et ce d'autant
plus que le gouvernement comme un
certain nombre de journalistes
malheureusement ne traite pas de manière
très rigoureuse
les statistiques du chômage avril se
focalise sur la fameuse catégorie un bon
que l'on voit c'est là c'est la ligne
bleu sur le graphique qui vient de
s'afficher autrement dit les personnes
sans emploi et faisant une recherche
active d'emploi mais il oublie qu'il ya
deux autres catégories qui sont dans les
chemins c'est d'abord la catégorie b ces
religions qui travaillent moins de 20
heures par mois et puis la catégorie d
et là ce sont les gens qui sont sans
emploi mais qui ont été pour des raisons
administratives
dispensé de faire une recherche active
alors ce qui est important de comprendre
c'est que oui effectivement le chômage a
fortement baissé pour la catégorie à
c'est une catégorie ou par rapport au
pic que l'on avait connu en avril 2020
et déjà une réduction de 1 million 200
mille personnes dans cette catégorie a
et on se retrouve actuellement sous le
niveau de décembre 2019 donc on peut
dire ça va bien mais si on prend les
catégories b et d là on voit que le
niveau est en fait supérieur d'environ
quelques dizaines de milliers de
personnes par rapport au niveau 2
décembre 2019 et si maintenant on
considère ce qu'on appelle le quasi
chômage autrement dit les catégories c
et e c'est à dire les gens qui sont au
si vous voulez qu'ils sont à mi temps de
manière contrainte et puis les gens qui
sont dans des emplois et des eti sans
ces aides effectivement ces emplois
n'existerait pas eh bien on constate que
le nombre global de gens qui sont dans
les catégories c et e et bien lui il a
augmenté de 200 milles par rapport à ce
qu'il était en novembre décembre 2010
photo d'arles nous nous retrouvons
toujours avec
6,1 6,2 millions de demandeurs d'emploi
autrement dit un chiffre qui est
équivalent à 2019 et alors si comme on
doit malheureusement s'y attendre la
reprise se ralentit en 2022 eh bien il
est très clair que le mouvement de
retour à l'emploi qui concerne il faut
le rappeler est essentiellement la
catégorie a est bien ce mouvement de
retour à l'emploi va se ralentir va se
stabiliser en fait mais si la situation
devait empirer autrement dit si on avait
des problèmes économiques qui devait
perdurer au delà du premier semestre eh
bien il faut craindre que l'on connaisse
probablement à l'horizon du quatrième
trimestre 2022 une nouvelle dégradation
importante en ce qui concerne le nombre
de demandeurs d'emploi mais jacques il
ya un autre problème aussi c'est de
l'inflation et donc du pouvoir d'achat
vous avez tout à fait raison et gorille
tout à fait raison l'inflation que nous
connaissons aujourd'hui est forte elle
est de 2,8 pour cent en france sur
l'année elle est aussi importante en
allemagne et elle était encore beaucoup
plus haute aux états unis alors la
question c'est de savoir si nous sommes
en face d'une inflation qui est purement
conjoncturel août randy liés aux p2ri
lié ou non à des tremblements bien si
elle a une dimension qui est plus
structurel
ce qui va dans le sens d'une inflation
conjoncturel c'est que effectivement on
a tous ce phénomène des pénuries des
goulots d'étranglement et on peut penser
que là ce pic d'inflation eh bien il
devrait durer
jusqu'à la fin du premier semestre de
2022 voire le début du deuxième semestre
2000 22 apr il devrait se tasser
progressivement
seulement il faut déjà savoir qu'il
devrait provoquer une baisse du pouvoir
d'achat de 0 5% au premier semestre de
2022 et qu'en réalité cette baisse sera
probablement plus importante en
particulier pour les faibles revenus
autrement dit pour les gens qui sont
dans les quatre premiers déciles et à
des revenus est ce que l'on sait moins
c'est que la crise de la copie 19 a
provoqué une baisse de la productivité
du travail et cette balle va
certainement durer durant l'ensemble de
l'année 2009 voire au delà or qui dit
baisse de la productivité dit aussi
évidemment hausse des coûts de
production et s'il y a de hausse des
coûts de production eh bien il est
évident qu'il y aura globalement une
hausse des prix enfin il faut comprendre
que nous sommes aujourd'hui dans un
contexte qui est assez différent avec le
contexte de 2019 et pour différentes
raisons d'abord il ya évidemment tous
les investissements que l'on veut faire
pour générer une mettre en place la
transition énergétique pour lutter
grosso modo contre le réchauffement
climatique c'est très bien il faut aussi
faire des investissements pour d'autres
choses en particulier dans les services
publics mais qui dit un gros effort
d'investissement dit aussi une certaine
manière nécessairement un effet
inflationniste
et puis on a les politiques des banques
centrales qui pour soutenir l'économie
ont énormément éjecté de mener dans
cette économie ce qui provoque
évidemment aussi des tensions
inflationnistes
la conclusion de tout cela c'est que la
question du pouvoir d'achat va être au
centre des préoccupations des français
et ce dans une année électorale
alors voilà qui ne va pas simplifier la
tâche du gouvernement ni celle du
président futur candidat donc les
perspectives ne sont pas encourageantes
mais vous savez grégory non mais y en
plus un autre problème sur lequel
malheureusement les gens sont volés les
responsables sont bien silencieux
actuellement et qui va se dévoiler très
probablement durant cette année c'est la
situation financière des entreprises
alors on sait que durant 2 milliards ou
plus haut de la crise de l'aco vide les
dames massivement aider les entreprises
mais il les a aidées essentiellement par
des garanties de crédit alors que dans
d'autres pays par exemple comme en
allemagne ou aux états unis il a plutôt
procédé à des subventions alors qu'est
ce que ça veut dire que ces garanties
crédibles ça veut dire que la charge
d'endettement de nombreuses entreprises
c'est en particulier le cas pour les pme
et les tpe s'est alourdi or avec la
situation compliquée que l'on connaît
dans le domaine sanitaire et qui risque
encore de durer pour plusieurs mois eh
bien il est très clair que la
consommation va marquer le parc on sait
qu'elles avaient baissé la consommation
de 7 % en 2020 elle avérée augmenté à
près de 4,2 pour cent en 2021 elle était
donc pas du tout revenu au niveau de
2019 est ce que l'on peut penser c'est
que elle ne reviendra pas en 2022 ni
même peut-être en 2023 au niveau de 2019
alors qu'est ce que ça veut dire on a
moins de consommation c'était la moins
de chiffre d'affaires et même avec
l'effet de l'inflation cela veut dire
que le flux de revenus sur lequel on
devrait payer les dettes accumulées en
2020 en particulier à travers les
cibler les prêts garantis par l'état les
fameux pge et bien on doit moins de
moyens pour rembourser cela il ya donc
un risque réel de faillite à l'horizon
du deuxième semestre 2022 et dans ces
conditions la solution la moins mauvaise
serait que l'état reprenne à sa charge
une partie de l'endettement des
entreprises mais évidemment cela
poserait la question de la dette de
l'état donc jacques en conclusion une
année 2009 délicate qui s'annonce sur le
plan économique pour le gouvernement
mais aussi pour les français
ah oui les gars loïs c'est absolument
indiscutable les problèmes de court
terme de moyens d avoir de l'eau dern
vont poser un problème tout à fait
redoutable au gouvernement l'année 2022
va être compliqué et pas seulement parce
qu'il s'agit d'une année électorale
quand il faudrait pour que le
gouvernement ne se perdent pas dans la
gestion de court voit de très court
terme autrement dit pour qu'il sorte la
tête du guidon ce qui est
malheureusement la situation dans lequel
il est actuellement qu'il dispose d'
orientation forte pour l'économie parce
que 2022 ça sera aussi une année
importante ça sera l'année dans laquelle
on doit rentrer dans le vif du sujet
pour la transition énergétique pour la
réindustrialisation de la france mais
aussi pour la housse il faut l'espérer
de la productivité
tout cela cela impliquerait que l'on ait
une forme de plan pour les années à
venir
saoulé cette idée le président macron
l'abeille rue il ad'ailleurs recréer un
dispositif qui s'appelle le haut
commissariat au plan qui est
actuellement présidée par monsieur
berrou en septembre 2020 seulement il en
a limité les fonctions de la prospective
ce qui est une erreur grave car on ne
peut pas se priver d'un tel instrument
d'action dont le besoin se fera de plus
en plus sentir dans les mois qui
viennent il faudrait que ceux haut
commissariat au plan retrouve les
attributions de ce qu était dans les
années 50 60 et 70 le commissariat
général au plan merci jacques sapir pour
ce panorama économique de l'année à
venir à la semaine prochaine pour un
nouvel édito échos
les pilotes du dakar vont ils devoir
couper les moteurs selon jean yves le
drian tout à l'heure la course qui a
lieu pour la deuxième année d'affilée en
arabie saoudite pourraient être
interrompues en cause l'explosion qui a
grièvement blessé le pilote français
philippe boutron le 30 décembre après
avoir un temps envisagé la piste
terroriste les autorités saoudiennes
landes depuis fermement rejetée elle
privilégie la thèse de l'accident
ministre français des affaires
étrangères lui se pose la question d'un
attentat
nous l'avons fait savoir très vite et
nous avons dit aux organisateurs et aux
responsables saoudiens qu'il fallait
être très transparent sur ce qui venait
de se passer parce qu'il y avait des
hypothèses selon lesquelles ça pouvait
être un acte terroriste
il y a déjà eu des actes terroristes en
arabie saudite contre les intérêts
français il y a peut-être eu un attentat
terroriste contre le dakar jean-pierre
connaissent à l auteur du livre docteur
saoud et mr djihad à la diplomatie
religieuse de l'arabie saoudite aux
éditions robert laffont il évoque des
actes de malveillance récurrent dans le
royaume wahhabite a
on a tout de suite nous occidentaux une
réaction d'aller chercher si c'était
raccrocher il faudra cocher al qaïda ou
à des ch moi je crois que
malheureusement ça te rhabiller quelque
chose de beaucoup plus profond
ce sont des actes de malveillance
qui sont le fait de saoudiens qui ne
sont pas obligatoirement accroché une
organisation et pour qui le système
d'enseignement le système culturel le
système religieux fait de ces gens là
des mécréants c'est à dire contre
lesquelles n'importe quelle forme de
violence est possible par exemple ces
jours ci il ya quelqu'un qui a tiré au
pistolet contre un garde de sécurité de
l'ambassade de france
lavedan le cas que vous évoquez il est
évident que ces cas une explosion que
cette explosion s'est produite par le
dessous du véhicule dont il avait une
charge ou une mine ou quelque chose
comme ça et les de la description qu'en
ont fait les passagers le lien penser
que c'est effectivement une bombe bon
donc si c'est une beau mais est ce que
c'est une bombe qu'il faut absolument
accrocher au terrorisme international ou
au contraire accroché à cet acte de
malveillance qui sont très fréquents
adpl c'est la fin de cette édition on se
retrouve dans une trentaine de minutes à
[Musique]
on vit tous les jours sans faire
attention que tout en dépend c'est
l'unité de mesure de toute chose
une convention admise par tous
s'il arrive quelque chose tout s'arrête
[Applaudissements]
vous conviendrez que c'est l'argent qui
fait tourner le monde
[Musique]
peu importe que ce soit des bitcoins ou
du bon vieux cash nous vous parlerons de
tout sans langue de bois
[Musique]
olivier maintenant détenu depuis huit
mois quelles sont les nouvelles les
nouvelles y en a très peu
malheureusement elles sont coupés de
tout il n'est pas dans un hôtel capturé
avec un téléphone et il peut me donner
des nouvelles non à votre avis quelles
sont ses conditions de détention
aujourd'hui c'est sûr elles sont très
difficiles parce que les anciens otages
ont pu nous le raconter qu'il a des
conditions de vie qui sont très
rudimentaires et très dur j'espère
vraiment de tout mon coeur qui qui
ressent notre énergie moi j'essaye de
faire de mon mieux bien sûr tout
simplement pour qu'ils m'entendent parce
que c'est ça mon travail c'est la france
et le mali où la france ou le mali qui
vont libérer olivier g pas ce pouvoir de
libérer